hey how you doing oh how are you
doing great listen i want to start for
all three of you congrats on the movie
you guys did such a great job i am
curious though um this movie has been
you guys filmed it like two years ago
i'm just curious how much have you been
texting alan and david being like so
when am i actually gonna be seeing this
in theaters
who's gonna take it
feel like i was texting everyone
constantly just being like what's going
on me and alessandra would try and get
information from each other i'd text
leslie i feel like we all um
we're just you know excited
to uh to even you know see the final
product i mean a lot of us haven't you
you know i saw it for the first time
probably
two months ago and and we've started in
2019 so i think we were just all really
um
anxiously excited for for you know i see
it
yeah yeah i mean i felt like it was
we were cast in 2018 it's been like
three years now i think
and uh you know this was like this sort
of
you know i felt like this was the
greatest role i'd ever been offered but
it was like those you know those like
dog races those greyhound and they like
dangle some like rabbit in front of them
and they keep like you know going to
grab it and then they pull it away
and they just keep running faster to try
and eat the thing yeah that's kind of
how it's spelled we've just just been
like slow torture
yeah it's interesting because david's
known for tinkering in the editing room
so
you know but it but anyway um one of the
things i just want to sort of get out
there for people is to realize that you
do not have to have seen the sopranos to
enjoy this movie and i'm so could you
sort of could you guys sort of just talk
about that that this is a standalone
film
yeah i mean well he he he built the the
story around a character that wasn't in
the you know that was gone before the
series began and only existed as a kind
of
mythological figure
and
you know and then and then building in
the whole uh
you know
racial question
was
so you know leslie's character is really
the the main counter balance to dickie
in the
film and that was a totally novel thing
to the show
um and then obviously
the the relationship between dicky and
tony is is um
you know something that is talked about
in the series but
hadn't really been explored and so the
movie exists completely as an autonomous
uh
creation and i think david really
wanted to do that and wanted to design
it with a different rhythm you know in a
a film format which is a a different
rhythm of storytelling and so yeah i
don't think that you have to have any
knowledge of the of the movie especially
because it takes place before the of the
sorry of the series because it takes
place before the series ever begins
um i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of any series any
movie for all three of you what do you
think might surprise people to learn
about the making of the movie and if you
don't have a story like that maybe you
could just share a great day on set
the surprise is that um
you know alessandro
is just the worst
no
um um a surprise
um
well allah i'm sure i don't know if
leslie has a story like this but
alessandro learned a a acting technique
from de niro apparently
in which he
would sort of
rev up to
saying his lines and and really like
repeat his line until he got really
present in in the moment
which is uh a helpful technique i'm sure
but when you aren't aware of it for the
first time you're you're very confused
on what's going on so
the first time is the first scene he he
says i'm like you know god
god could hear you so we're like doing
the scene and he's like god god you know
god god god could god could god god
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think you know one of the one of the
most memorable moments for me was like
was that first dinner guys remember like
after the we did the first read-through
and then we all went to a big cast
dinner in brooklyn i think it was
brooklyn
and uh michael made a speech which is
really said david made his speech on his
beach it was um you know it was this
kind of thing uh we'd all found our way
to this uh you know
to this project that we all knew was
really special but there's something
about that dinner uh and us
you know being welcomed into the family
i think that made it all very real and
it set a nice tone for the for the shoot
my uh most surprising thing was the
first scene that we shot together you
know i had i had to smack him it's a
scene it got cut so you'll never see it
but well maybe you were on the dvd
extras or whatever but uh you know i had
to i had to whack him and uh
you know we started shooting and i
started whacking him and like i don't
think he was expecting that you know and
then i'd forgotten that that he turns
around and whacks me
and so i like like i smacked him like
three times or whatever and then
suddenly he turned around and smacked me
and
everything is hitting each other
yeah that was a
surprise um i got to stop there i'm just
going to say again you three were great
in this congrats on the movie uh i hope
it's a huge hit for you guys
thank you thanks so much take care
you